the obvious things are not what
people
observe the duffer brothers are not ones
to waste time so honestly they don't
tend to cut too much material from
stranger things but there are a lot of
choices to be made in the writing room
and during filming want to find out just
how different season four could have
been
people just change
okay
i've changed
it's that simple
number one we would have revolted if max
went the way of the demo dodo bird the
duffers weren't always sure what they
wanted max's fate to be and we could
have seen a very different ending to
season 4 if they weren't such sensitive
sally's we'll get into that more in a
minute but in their minds the danger she
was in was real just like eddie she was
faded from the beginning of the season
to not make it to the end but her role
in the coma has been hinted at being
super important in the next season do
they know
when she'll awake
more mind fights that's our guess do you
have a better theory for max it's been
really cool i feel like each season you
kind of see a different side of her
number two one of the staples of season
four was another last minute edition
eddie almost didn't have that big
metallica ending if it wasn't for the
pandemic slowing down the filming
process they would have been well into
filming the first few episodes before
deciding eddie needed to not just love
metallica but to be part of a band so
once they decided to add that awesome
ending they got to go back and layer in
the band and layer in eddie's guitar in
that episode one scene with chrissy they
weren't just able to layer in the band
but we were able to humanize him we were
able to
humanize him number three it could have
been the enzo for enzo that sounds like
a dumb joke yuri would make enzo didn't
always make it to the end of the season
duffers didn't go into too much detail
about the situation but there wasn't
much of a reason to off him so they just
decided to let him have his happily ever
after besides it gets a little weird
when you keep taking out side characters
and your main characters consistently
just have brushes with the light at the
end of the tunnel they said i think
there was a version where dimitri aka
enzo didn't make it yes but still alive
number four now to deviate to netflix's
weird marketing here are a few words
about eddie from from the closest tim
it's no secret that fans are infuriated
about the fate of the coolest character
to join the show one eddie munson but
come on he had the most epic death scene
ever and we should all be so lucky we
got to witness it well netflix in some
sort of cruel form of parody released a
fake eulogy for eddie and we will agree
it's tacky tacky tacky wherever you are
i
hope you give him hellfire
except for this great line from joe kiri
finally
someone who could compete with such just
a beautiful flow
after all the love joe's hair has
received over the years it's nice to see
him acknowledge his competition do you
think this whole thing was scripted like
every day i wake up and i'm like what
the heck happened number five if he were
a female praying mantis maybe the design
would have worked vecna understands us
on a human level stranger things could
have been a very different beast
altogether if they went with some of
their other vechna concept art one in
particular sticks out as an odd choice
with henry's fascination for spiders and
that was a design that made him look
like a praying mantis instead so we want
to know what came first the intertwined
spider plot or the mantis we can only
assume with the look of the mind flare
that the spiders were here first the
problem with the mantis though was the
duffer brothers insisted on having a
practical design for vechna this is
really the first time since season one
that we're going back to
the world of prosthetics and the mantis
was just too darn tall creepy though
vecna did get a little less buggy than
he could have been in one iteration he
had the eyes of a spider too this
character is not chaos number six there
were around 50 demos of the demo bat
seriously the designs were infinite with
this one once upon a time the demo bats
were more like demogorgons and demo dogs
than their own thing with heads and
bodies that split open much in the same
way this just wasn't a creative enough
choice oh and they also had serrated
tails that cut you when they wrapped
themselves around you unfortunately this
made them just too dangerous and they
would have taken out steve rather than
just injure him and we know how the
duffers feel about that it's like it's
either what i imagine or is even better
than what i imagine number seven it's
better for an actor's financial
situation millie joked that the
showrunners needed to start killing
people off to which noah agreed millie
called them sensitive sallys and
demanded more game of thrones
unrelenting offing of characters is
there some jealousy there she did once
audition for game of thrones and almost
gave up on acting when she didn't land
the role i think i was just very
disheartened by the rejection matt
duffer said believe us we've explored
all of it all options in the writing
room just as a complete hypothetical you
kill mike it's like that's depressing
we're not depressing we aren't game of
thrones every death on stranger things
has a lasting impact
billy wake up billy get up
every life is worth something so it's
hard for them to take out a character
because it changes dynamics it changes
story lines barb billy eddie the kids in
the lab alexi hopper for a minute and a
half it changes the course of everything
and honestly the duffers just don't want
to exhaust plot lines around that kind
of stuff matt carried on so imagine mike
dying it's like is that something we're
interested in exploring or not
interested in exploring that's it this
is the beginning of the end and i read
it and i was just bawling i was so upset
number eight there's a ton of subtly
unsettling choices here time for you
to join me
the plan for vecna's lair at one point
leaned very heavily into the idea of the
spider's web by the looks of it that was
a bit impractical to have them dangling
from the sky imagine filming that talk
about a head rush so tying them against
pillars via the vines wound up being far
more comfortable but that wasn't the
only scrapped design designer michael
marr jr described on his website it
might be fun to play with a large vortex
where fragments of the house were
dissolving along with spires containing
rotted victims everything would be
moving slowly swirling in a circular
motion the anti-gravity inspiration of
this one will come back the next was
inspired by the thriller horror movie
the cell another unsettling description
by michael in early iterations of the
script vecna would drag his victims
through a blood-filled area on his way
to a massive monolithic structure in the
distance you can see the bakzinski
influence here exciting for us in that
way that there's a lot of story being
uncovered here number nine improv can
change the course of a show sometimes
another moment we almost didn't have was
eddie's final line to dustin that i love
you man was totally spoken from the
heart in the heat of the moment
i loved you dad
man we are not looking forward to seeing
dustin's grieving in the next season
poor guys too wholesome for that
number 10 we sincerely don't think we
could stomach patchwork fakna especially
if they chose this design he looks like
such a happy guy we doubt we'd be scared
at all the hair idea was scrapped pretty
quick though do you think they got any
of their inspiration from toby maguire's
spider-man so vampire skin was also on
the table michael pitched that his skin
could be rotting away due to all the
time he's spent in the upside down and
henry might be trying to clamp it
together to try and save it he also got
a cloak in one design perhaps because
it's too easy to recognize who he is in
some of them gangrene and radiation raw
were also popular choices oh and
asymmetry was attempted we can only
imagine how any one of these designs may
change the look and feel of the show
number 11. who would have thought dust
could be so fascinating
dimension x is where henry lands in the
upside down it's where the mind flare
exists as a floating living entity of
dust particles but it wasn't always just
swarming like bees gravity works
differently in this realm we told you
this idea would resurface and well the
floating rocks were once where these
particles came from henry would harvest
them however this idea was too
convoluted and wound up scrapped
all i needed was someone to open the
door
and he did that for me
number 12. the designs are far more
intimidating than the fish from which
they came we find it a bit odd that for
a bit their inspiration came from fish
prehistoric ones at that one called a
dunkleosteus whose idea was it to jump
from aliens and spiders and other spooky
creepy things to fish we wonder if that
has something to do with watergate who
knows once again
you have freed me
number 13. oh to be faded to only work
one season with every death the duffer
brothers weigh heavily the effects it
has on its characters well dustin is in
for an interesting arc in season five
thanks to their choice to take out eddie
they didn't make the decision lightly
though but the story basically demanded
he not make it out alive we're just glad
he went down a hero and not a sacrifice
like vecna's earlier victims where is
eddie now
number 14. this was the best last minute
edition in the history of last minute
editions we almost didn't get that
protective brother coded scene in the
pizza joint from jonathan and will they
were mid-filming with jonathan looking
in the rearview mirror at will when they
realized they needed a supportive big
brother scene we're glad to see will
isn't feeling as alone now as alone as
he has been since he disappeared into
the upside down and i'll always be here
no matter what
because you're my brother number 15.
imagine watching this show on vhs in the
80s the duffer brothers are pushing hard
for the audience to watch stranger
things as if it's existing in that time
period they really want netflix to
release it on vhs if not on vhs to at
least overlay it with that feel of the
panon scan it will give a whole new
nostalgia feel to the series to be on
the ball for four seasons now we've got
pretty good reassurance that the final
season won't disappoint drop your
theories about where the upside down
came from in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things